merci Jacqueline messagerie d'être avec
nous pour cette première demi-heure et
lui du Val-d'Oise membre du groupe les
républicains on va parler de votre
groupe de travail sur la
transidentification dans quelques
instants mais d'abord l'actualité on l'a
vu dans le journal c'est cette
proposition de loi du groupe Hut qui
vise à abroger la réforme des retraites
qui est donc examiné aujourd'hui en
commission à l'Assemblée Éric Coquerel
la déclaré recevable est-ce qu'il faut
que le débat se tienne et que le vote a
lieu selon vous je pense qu'il faut
arrêter sur ce sujet voilà Éric je sais
pas si c'est exprimé en tant que
président la commission des finances ou
en tant que député LFI c'est quand même
le vrai sujet
pour vous que le déclarer et
rappelons quand même que le débat autour
des retraites à l'Assemblée ça a pas été
un débat c'était un Champ Champ de foi
en face a été de l'obstruction
parlementaire permanent des défis qui je
le rappelle n'a pas voté ce texte parce
qu'ils sont allés à l'article 4 le Sénat
voté le texte le Sénat travailler un
jour et nuit sur ce sujet parce que
c'est vrai que c'était compliqué mais
c'est notre rôle sauf qu'à l'Assemblée
elle affiche je rappelle à part [__]
le bazar excusez-moi l'expression
pendant deux semaines non pas voter donc
à un moment il faut arrêter ce petit jeu
certes des Français ne sont pas contents
sur en tout cas l'âge de la retraite
certes il y a des difficultés mais
enfin quand on est un homme ou une femme
politique faut pas vouloir toujours
aller dans le sens du vent il faut aussi
avoir la l'honnêteté l'honnêteté de
poser les difficultés avec réalisme
voilà quand
il y a quelques temps il faut aller
jusqu'à 65 parce que c'est quand même ça
ce groupe disait en tout cas ce député
disait on doit aller jusqu'à 65 que le
texte votait ses 64 il va pas tellement
de cohérence et de toute façon il faut
arrêter de faire penser aux Français
avec ce texte a une chance aboutir il
n'aboutira jamais donc quoi c'est quoi
de bazar remettre voilà un climat
compliqué dans ce pays on a franchement
pas besoin de ça ça a été compliqué le
temps des retraites bon voilà je pense
que les gens se sont exprimés les
manifestations ont eu lieu c'est la
règle c'est la démocratie maintenant la
loi est votée la loi doit être appliquée
l'autre actualité c'est Gabriel Attal
qui a dévoilé hier son plan de lutte
contre la fraude sociale à 3 semaines
après celui contre la fraude fiscale
alors Gabriel Attal il veut durcir les
conditions de résidence pour toucher des
allocations il faudra résider 9 mois en
France il veut renforcer les contrôles
des retraités installés à l'étranger
est-ce que c'est un plan que vous
soutenez moi ça ne me pose aucun
problème de lutter contre la fraude on
lutte contre la France de celles et ceux
qui trichent pour leurs impôts on doit
aussi lutter contre les yeux qui
trichent avec toutes les prestations
sociales en général et hier j'ai une
petite nuance qui m'a un petit peu gênée
dans les propos
je ne cherche pas les frotteurs je veux
lutter contre la fraude non on doit
rechercher les fraudeurs et pointer des
fraudeurs et faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait plus de fraudeur à toutes ces
prestations donc bien évidemment tout ça
c'est un sujet sur lequel on avait
c'était déjà positionné sur la fraude en
matière sociale parce que les
conséquences sont financièrement quand
même très très lourdes et puis la fraude
c'est pas moi c'est pas un mode de
comportement dans un pays de donc il y a
aucune raison que moi je sois que je
n'accompagne pas on vous dites ça va pas
assez loin on va proposer il faut alors
c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu alors sur la
carte d'identité associée à à la carte
Vitale
réaliste ça c'est pas moi qui peut
répondre aujourd'hui d'autres mais ça
vous ferez une bonne idée la Belgique le
fait donc je sais pas pourquoi la
française le problème c'est que je pense
que ça c'est pas demain donc il y avait
aussi la carte de biométrique de la
carte Vitale qu'on avait proposé qui
pourrait être le problème c'est que la
carte biométrique elle peut être
appliquée tout de suite et tout de suite
on aura effectivement des milliers et
des milliers et des milliers de gens qui
seraient face à une réalité mais tant
pis je pense que il faut qu'on fasse
comprendre aux fraudeur que la France a
cessé
l'autre sujet encore d'actualité c'est
la question de l'immigration les
républicains ont proposé deux textes un
texte constitutionnel et une proposition
de loi ordinaire Gérald Darmanin vous
tend la main et vous dit chiche
travaillant ensemble vous êtes prêt à
travailler avec lui travailler ensemble
je pense que nous nous n'avons jamais
été opposés à travailler ensemble ce
sujet mais c'est travailler ensemble
avec l'idée qu'il faut qu'il accepte ce
que nous voulons nous il y a des lignes
rouges sur lequel nous changerons pas
vous le savez aujourd'hui d'abord est-ce
que du coup un compromis possible alors
je ne sais pas c'est pas moi qui peut
vous dire aujourd'hui
d'avoir parce que ça m'appartient pas à
titre personnel mais nous avançons alors
après d'abord quand ce texte a-t-il
arrivé parce que quand même depuis deux
mois c'est l'automne puis c'est juillet
puis là c'est octobre donc déjà le texte
on ne sait pas quand il va arriver le
texte du Gouvernement avec quoi on ne le
sait pas encore
examen d'ici la fin de l'année oui bah
déjà vous voyez on devait l'avoir en
mars puis après on l'a eu en octobre
puis après c'est en juillet et là c'est
difficile
je pense que c'est un sujet essentiel
aujourd'hui pour notre pays nous ne
pouvons plus gérer l'immigration telle
qu'il est tel que voilà les textes le
prévoit aujourd'hui parce que la France
doit reprendre la main la France doit
pouvoir dire ce qu'elle veut en matière
d'immigration voilà on ne peut pas
parce que
Gérald Darmanin moi je pense que c'est
pour ça que à juste titre les LR veulent
inscrire dans la Constitution à certains
de nos choses de manière à ce que la
France reprenne la main et la France a
le droit de dire ce qu'elle veut en
matière d'immigration c'est un des pays
qui accueille le plus en Europe voilà
moi je vous donne juste des chiffres à
la fin de 2012 il y avait 2 millions 6
étrangers en France nous en sommes
aujourd'hui en 2012 en 2022 à 3 millions
7 vous voyez quand même en disant voilà
donc on voit bien que ces flux
migratoires nous sommes débordés ne
savons plus les gérer il y a un coût
évidemment il y a faut le dire des
problèmes de sécurité parce que quand
vous laissez sur le trottoir des gens
qui ont pas qui n'ont pas de situation
évidemment ça génère des choses et puis
voilà ne pas lier certains problèmes de
sécurité après une migration c'est
complètement dans le déni dans
l'hypocrisie parce que est-ce que votre
ex pourront aller au bout ne serait-ce
qu'au Sénat on voit que les centristes
ont déposé leur propre position de loi
est-ce que c'est un sujet qui va diviser
la majorité c'est naturel non moi je
pense qu'on peut se retrouver il faut
juste que chacun comprenne ce vers quoi
nous voulons aller reprendre la main en
matière d'immigration mais c'est
essentiel et c'est urgent et d'ailleurs
si vous regardez tous les sondages qui
sortent mais tous sans exception il
prouve ce que nous avons raison et y
compris dans un électorat de gauche qui
comprend bien qu'on ne peut pas les
au-delà de ce que nous vivons et qui va
falloir que nous ayons des une ligne
très claire sur ce que nous voulons
vraiment
on va parler de du Sénat vous allez
travailler sur la question des
changements de sexe chez les mineurs
enfants adolescents votre groupe de
travail et lancer aujourd'hui on fait le
point d'abord avec notre journaliste
parlementaire si le jour non
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour madame la sénatrice
et Steve le Sénat lance donc aujourd'hui
un groupe de travail sur la
transidentité des mineurs c'est une
demande du groupe les républicains la
transidentification qu'est-ce que c'est
il faut mettre un peu d'ordre parce que
effectivement on entend beaucoup de
choses à ce sujet alors être trans ou
transgenre c'est ne pas s'identifier à
son sexe biologique je suis né homme
mais je me sens femme je suis né femme
et je me sens homme ou encore je suis né
homme mais je ne me sens ni homme ni
femme mon dit alors que je suis non
binaire précisons et c'est important
Oriane que la transidentité n'est pas
liée à l'orientation sexuelle ont
peut-être transgenre et bisexuel
transgenre et hétéro ou encore
transgenre et homosexuel à noter qu'il a
fallu attendre 2010 pour que la
transidentité soit retirée de la liste
des maladies mentales ces roses Bachelot
ministre de la Santé sous Nicolas
Sarkozy qui en était à l'initiative
l'OMS a suivi c'était en 2018 et la
transidentité est un sujet qui est
intéressant beaucoup droite oui
rappelez-vous pendant la dernière
campagne présidentielle Valérie Pécresse
avait demandé à ce qu'on interdit ce
mineur les opérations chirurgicales et
visant à changer de sexe elle avait été
un peu raillée car aujourd'hui la
législation est plutôt claire les
interventions chirurgicales de
changement de sexe sont réservés
exclusivement en majeur depuis de 18 ans
alors il est vrai qu'aucun texte de loi
non cadre ou n'interdit ses opérations
mais les médecins se plient aux
recommandations d'associations
internationales qui préconisent datant
de la majorité avant d'intervenir
aujourd'hui les sénateurs LR envisagent
de légiférer sur la question d'où la
création d'un groupe de travail regarde
parce que certains jeunes notamment en
pleine crise d'adolescence s'interroge
sur leur identité et souhaite entamer
des démarches sans attendre oui ce qu'il
est possible de faire aujourd'hui ce
sont des parcours dit de transition ils
sont entamés avant la majorité de
l'individu au moment de la puberté pas
avant le parcours est très balisé les
médecins c'est sûr d'abord qu'ils sont
confrontés un cas de transidentité si
c'est le cas on passe à l'étape suivante
avec l'accord des parents un traitement
hormonal est administré à l'adolescent
l'objectif c'est de bloquer les effets
de la puberté ça peut être utile quand
un ado n'est pas à l'aise dans son sexe
de naissance ça peut notamment permettre
d'éviter des tentatives de suicide par
exemple que le malaise est très profond
il faut préciser que c'est bloqueur de
puberté sont réversibles et qu'un
certain nombre d'adolescents les
abonnements en cours de route je vous
vois aussi la tête madame asiatrice
peut-être on peut revenir sur ce groupe
de travail votre objectif on a entre
nous vous pouvez nous le dire c'est
d'interdire ces parcours de transition à
terme nous ce que nous voulons c'est
alerter sur
les mineurs aujourd'hui il y a de
véritables dérives d'ailleurs il y avait
eu je l'ai retrouvé en 2021 une tribune
dans l'Express de mes seins de
chercheurs d'intellectuels qui est donc
il y a deux ans déjà un qui qui
s'intitulaire ou notre font plus nous
taire face à une grave dérive voilà
c'était j'avais pas inventé j'avais pas
cosiné cette tribune mais c'est un vrai
sujet on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que on
mélange un peu tout sur la problématique
de l'adolescence l'adolescence pour tous
les adolescents c'est un mot un moment
assez compliqué on se cherche on se
trouve plus ou moins tôt mais
aujourd'hui on a une espèce de dérive
qui consiste à dire parce qu'un
adolescence se questionne sur ce qu'il
est obligatoirement il veut changer de
sexe j'ai envie de dire je résume un peu
schématiquement et nous on veut vraiment
poser cette question parce qu'on
s'aperçoit d'ailleurs que il faut qu'on
comprenne pourquoi c'est un phénomène
qui touche beaucoup plus les filles que
les garçons beaucoup plus de filles
quand regarde les parce qu'en France on
a pas tellement de chiffres et on veut
avoir des chiffres ça parce que on va
parler de hausse croissante de ces
demandes on a aucun chiffre
dans les pays étrangers il y en a aux
États-Unis il y en a on suit il y en a
euh dans les Pays-Bas en or Royaume-Uni
on a et en disant dans ces pays-là les
chefs les chiffres ont explosé alors
pourquoi ils ont explosé parce qu'il y a
aussi des associations très activistes
dans ce phénomène et on a un ennemi un
ennemi entre guillemets c'est YouTube et
les réseaux sociaux qui effectivement
entraîne les gamins parce qu'ils sont
pas bien vers probablement des choses
qui les dépassent les gamins voilà et
nous on veut vraiment poser ça quand
vous dites tout à l'heure que
effectivement en France les opérations
ne sont pas encadrées mais ne sont pas
faites voilà quand vous dites que
donner des bloqueurs de puberté ordonnée
des hormon inverser tout ça si on arrête
c'est pas grave mais on n'en sait rien
aujourd'hui on n'en sait rien ça peut on
peut effectivement avoir des
conséquences graves pour la suite je
veux dire c'est très important et
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que ces gamins
qui se posent des questions
qu'ils deviennent enfin qui choisissent
de changer sexe adulte etc moi ce que ce
que nous voulons c'est faire attention à
ce qui se passe sur cette jeunesse qui a
parfois 12 13 14 ans et parfois plus
petit quand on a vu un reportage
récemment à la télé d'une maman qui
accompagnait son petit gamin enfin voilà
comprendre faut faire comprendre aux
parents que un enfant qui est pas bien
il a besoin souvent d'un soutien
psychologique pour poser les choses et
non pas rentrer dans ce qu'il demande
obligatoirement tout de suite et donc
voilà donc moi je pense qu'il faut enfin
aujourd'hui le groupe de travail veut
absolument poser ces questions parce que
c'est un problème de société
travaux on va pas changer notre cerveau
on va changer l'apparence physique il
faut aussi le dire ce qui est pas un
sujet chacun fait ce qu'il veut voilà
mais on change son apparence physique
mais faut pas croire que ça se fait dans
la joie et la bonne humeur enfin tout ça
c'est un choix et d'ailleurs on souhaite
interroger nous des trans adulte qui
sont les premiers à dire ce n'est pas
simple cette démarche voilà la société
doit avoir un regard tout à fait
objectif et soutenant sur ces gens qui
changent de sexe il y a aucun sujet mais
eux-mêmes disent ce n'est pas un
parcours si simple et on ne peut pas
laisser des gamins et des petits des
gargouilles des petits partir vers
quelque chose qui va les dépasser et ça
c'est notre rôle de parlementaire de le
dire de le poser donc on va
effectivement installer ce groupe
aujourd'hui alors vous allez procéder
donc
[Musique]
un nombre de professionnels au
Royaume-Uni pour avoir un échange sur
ces pays qui reculent parce que la Suède
a beaucoup beaucoup reculé quand elle a
vu le phénomène en disant explosé la
seule a pris des décisions très très
clair sur ce sujet donc c'est
intéressant aussi d'avoir cette
expérience je pense que la France n'en
est pas aussi loin que la semaine en été
il y a deux ou trois ans quand elle a
fait marche arrière mais c'est justement
posons-nous les questions aujourd'hui
les différencier a nécessité de
légiférer moi je pense qu'il le faut et
l'objectif c'est d'aboutirer l'objectif
voilà de travailler voilà mais en posant
la réalité des choses et en travaillant
avec les familles également parce que
des familles sont démunis parce que les
familles ils savent pas toujours comment
réagir ils sont parfois perdus
merci Steve merci on parlera de
sécheresse tout à l'heure et ce sera à
suivre dans le club et on suivra bien
sûr votre argent qui sont donc lancés
aujourd'hui on continue à regarder
l'actualité l'actualité dans nos régions
veulent encore si on retrouve Henri
Mariani bonjour merci d'être avec nous
directeurs délégués de Corse-Matin et on
va revenir sur l'une des actualités
d'hier c'est la commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur l'agression mortelle
d'Yvan colonne qui a donc rendu ses
conclusions qu'est-ce qu'on y apprend
Henri
pas grand chose je dirais si ce n'est
des dysfonctionnements chroniques des
manquements de l'incompétence très
probablement mais en tout cas on ne sait
toujours pas ce qui a motivé Franck et
longue abbé de passer à l'acte il n'y a
rien quant au mobile de cette agression
alors bien évidemment ça n'est pas à la
Commission de déterminer c'est un
enquête pénale qui est en cours de le
faire il en demeure pas moins qu'après
six mois d'audition et des dizaines et
dizaines de personnes entendues de
responsables de l'administration
pénitentiaire l'ancien Premier ministre
agent Castex des politiques des
policiers des gendarmes la commission
d'enquête parlementaire n'est toujours
pas en mesure de dire ce qui a armé le
bras du du tueur même la thèse du
blasphème sous des mots cette thèse qui
avait émergé au moment de l'agression
qui vend Colonna a été écarté ils vont
que le nain qui selon les guérisseurs
aurait tenu des propos insultants
vis-à-vis de la religion sur leur état
cité Franck et longue Abé a passé à
l'acte même ça ça a été écarté par la
commission d'enquête parlementaire en
revanche la Commission et vous l'avez
dit dans vos reportages précédents
pointent un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements et les demandesment
et ça interroge quand au parcours
carcéral de Franck elongabe rappelons
que c'est des tenues fiché s radicalisé
mise en examen dans des dossiers
terroristes et bien on était au sein de
la maison d'arrêt d'Arles un peu comme
chez lui il était au milieu des autres
détenus circulaient de cellules en
cellule de couloir en couloir et de
coursier en coursive avait le statut
d'auxiliaire c'est-à-dire qu'il
travaillait il avait accès à la salle de
sport là où a eu lieu l'agression des
colonnes salle de sport par ailleurs
protégée par des caméras de
vidéosurveillance donc à la commission
d'enquête parlementaire s'interroge et
se demande pour quelle raison Franck est
longue à blé n'était pas à l'isolement
compte tenu de son passé judiciaire
rappelons et c'est écrit dans le rapport
que Franck Elong abbé totalisé une
trentaine d'agressions je crois 29
exactement depuis depuis son
incarcération pourquoi bénéficier t-il
d'une telle mensuétude de la part de
l'administration pénitentiaire était-il
un agent de l'administration
pénitentiaire c'est-à-dire que
faisait-il remonter à sa direction des
informations
puiser au sein de la maison d'arrêt
information par exemple en lien avec la
lutte contre contre le terrorisme est-ce
qu'il avait donc ce statut un peu un peu
particulier
d'agents non officiel qui aurait pu
justifier qu'il ne soit pas à
l'isolement
ce sont des questions qui sont pour
l'instant sans réponse ce serait
effectivement je crois maintenant à
l'enquête pénale d'aller plus loin et de
pousser les investigations et d'éclairer
ces zones d'ombres que la commission
d'enquête parlementaire n'a pas pu
éclaircir et Henri vous avez des
questions justement pour pour la scène
adresse
oui bonjour madame la sénatrice en 2003
Dominique
perversaux ministre de la Justice de
Jacques Chirac président de la
République crée donc les ligiers c'est
les juridictions interagiales
spécialisées qui lutte contre le crime
organisé et annonce à ce moment-là la
création de 15 à 20 000 places de prison
supplémentaires plan repris par Nicolas
Sarkozy lors de son de son quinquennat
20 ans après on se rend compte qu'on est
loin du compte la France est toujours à
la traîne en termes de du nombre de
places de prison par par habitant du
coup ce serait pas l'impression que la
droite hormis des incantations et des
promesses n'a pas fait mieux que les
autres sur sur ce point là vous me
rappelez des informations de 2003
c'était il y a 20 ans donc oui oui non
mais il y a 20 ans donc effectivement on
aurait pu construire des places de
prison supplémentaires je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous après je
pense que la France de 2003 et la France
de 2023 c'est pas du tout la même
aujourd'hui on est face à également
voilà on n'est pas du tout du tout du
tout sous la même enfin nous ne vivons
pas dans la même France la France il y a
20 ans la France d'aujourd'hui c'est pas
la même aujourd'hui malheureusement et
ce que vous disiez sur Yvan Colona le
prouve nous avons affaire aujourd'hui à
une violence qui se qualifie d'ailleurs
avec il y a plusieurs qualificatifs et
effectivement Nicolas Sarkozy quand même
faut quand même rappeler qu'il est plus
président depuis de mandats que
effectivement les promesses de permettre
n'ont peut-être pas été tenues mais les
promesses de ces successeurs pas non
plus vraiment donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a on est face à une
réalité
qui qui qui consiste à dire que beaucoup
de gens qui sont à l'extérieur devraient
être en prison mais nous n'avons plus de
place que ce soit Hollande ou que ce
soit le président Macron on attend
encore aujourd'hui effectivement à
l'intérieur même de mes prisons et vous
l'avez souligner il y a des gens
extrêmement dangereux extrêmement
dangereux et c'est le cas de celui qui a
tué van Colonna qui sont pas mis à
l'isolement faute d'organisation des
prisons donc on est dans cette réalité
là aujourd'hui et moi je le déplore moi
j'ai aucun souci pour protéger la
société il faut faire des places de
prison donc ça c'est clair il y a des
gens qui n'ont rien à faire dehors voilà
on a deux sujets compliqués à tout ça
cette violence on a le manque crucial de
place de prison et aussi il faut pas le
sous-estimer
pas de de plan sur la psychiatrie en
France c'est un vrai sujet aussi la
psychiatrie donc voilà donc on a ces
deux volets là où effectivement on est
entre guillemets à la ramasse et
aujourd'hui va le constat c'est que
dehors il y a plein de gens qui ne
devraient pas être dehors voilà un
dernier mot peut-être Henri sur la
gestion des détenus radicalisés parce
que c'est aussi ça que la question qu'on
peut se rapport
oui oui c'est vrai la sénatrice le
rappelait effectivement il y a une
difficulté avec les quartiers
d'isolement pour aller les individus
fichés les individus radicalisés ceux
qui sont mis en examen dans des dossiers
terroristes il y a du mal il y a pas les
structures et les infrastructures
nécessaires au sein des prisons des
maisons d'arrêt pour isoler ces détenus
et qu'il ne cohabitent pas avec les
autres détenus les faire cohabiter avec
les autres détenus c'est aussi prendre
le risque de prosélytisme en prison de
radicalisation en prison on le voit bien
à l'aune des différents rapports
parlementaires et de ce que disent aussi
les les gardiens de prison donc c'est
effectivement un vrai sujet et je
rejoins effectivement je me rejoins
madame la sénatrice effectivement la
situation a évolué de manière
extrêmement négative pour autant je n'ai
pas l'impression que les politiques et
les pouvoirs publics et pris la mesure
de cette de cette évolution tout au
moins de 100 degré de gravité vous avez
raison vous avez raison ça veut dire
qu'il faut prendre de nouvelles mesures
non mais aujourd'hui on pourrais pas
faire comme si ça n'existait pas notre
environnement voilà on le voit bien et
vous avez raison de dire ce que vous
dites monsieur voilà que ce soit en
matière de trafic de drogue on va dire
vous avez vu enfin je veux dire les
choses voilà il y a pas il y a pas un
jour dans ce pays en tout cas
aujourd'hui où il y a pas une fusillade
où il y a pas un quelqu'un qui a des
problèmes psychiatriques qui qui pose
des problèmes graves donc oui oui il y a
urgence à poser les choses et pas être
dans le déni quoi voilà il y a peut-être
des choses qui ont pas été faites mais
voilà aujourd'hui avançons parce que il
est grand temps et il y a urgence à le
faire vraiment on va remercier hen merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous pour la
première fois dans cette émission on
était ravi de vous avoir et à très vite
Henri on regarde la Une de Corse-Matin
le rapport accablon de la commission
colonne c'est à la Une de Corse-Matin
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup à un dernier
mot puisque on parlait de radicalisation
c'est un dossier que vous suivez
particulièrement c'est les suites de
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty puisque
c'était dans votre département le Sénat
va s'emparer du sujet il y a une enquête
qui va être lancée c'est ce qui a
annoncé le président de la commission
des lois vous souhaitez que ce soit une
commission d'enquête où ça va être
compliqué étant donné qu'il y a des
idées si c'est une commission d'enquête
une commission en tout cas le président
buffet c'est positionné c'est encore une
commission et je pense qu'il y a urgence
à faire une commission l'affaire papier
et l'exemple criant criant de d'un homme
courageux d'un ancien nom exceptionnel
qui a été abandonné lâché vraiment quand
on voit aujourd'hui
par l'État par ses collègues par des
syndicats par tout le monde il s'est
retrouvé seul s'est retrouvé seul et ça
je pense que la famille a besoin que ce
soit posé à besoin que ce soit dit et a
besoin que celles et ceux qui n'ont pas
accompagné qui n'ont pas voulu
comprendre qu'ils ont aussi accusé
d'être d'avoir été peut-être trop loin
dans sa manière d'enseigner etc et bien
cela on doit les poser on doit le dire
vraiment c'est extrêmement important de
la famille n'oublions pas un professeur
décapité dans sa ville c'est juste ça
qui veut et je voudrais juste terminer
pas il est tout à fait anormal que le
collège dans lequel il a enseigné ne
porte pas son nom aujourd'hui ça c'est
absolument anormal
qui doit porter le nom de Samuel Paty
c'est le collège au sens unique du
courage ça nécessite du courage de la
part des politiques de la part de
l'éducation nationale c'est une
obligation pour moi et et peut-être ça
donnera l'envie à d'autres communes de
le faire également merci beaucoup merci
Jacqueline de stage réunion et d'avoir
été avec nous pendant cette première
demi-heure